[Musique]
vous avez remarqué que dès notre
naissance les gens croient tout savoir
sur vous quand vous voyez vous dites les
gros ou je fais peur et avec loin c'est
un peu plus
et j'ai failli tuer par bon vieux
continent avec une guitare fait des
petits mots gentils garçons jusqu'au
jour où je les laisse au tout a changé
par les créateurs de rio et de l'âge de
glace
la compagnie présente les nouveaux je ne
connais pas mais moi j'ai pas peur de
toi andy tu parles à ses fesses là tu
parle à mes fesses c'est l'avantagé tout
qui m'appelle una moi c'est moi qui ai
passé outre s il faut que je rentre chez
moi quand on fait attention au spoil a
pu échapper
j'aimerais pas être toi tu auras mon
traître
dehors il ya des endroits où on n'est
pas maltraité juste pour ce qu'on est
je vais partir d'ici et je laisserai
personne derrière moi c'est un plan
génial
à la maison les amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle offrez vous la plus énorme des
aventures
apa
c'est du gâteau
j'adore le ghetto ferdinand
[Musique]